well joe let me set the scene uh first
of all for everybody so
last night going into today clearly
there are signs of
a diplomatic opening there always has
been an opportunity to to talk
there are grounds for a conversation uh
about uh about ukraine with ukraine and
that's good we know we are seeing
russian openness to uh to conversations
on the other hand the intelligence that
we're seeing today is is still not
encouraging we've got
uh russian field hospitals being
constructed uh near the border with
ukraine in in belarus for you know only
can be construed as a preparation for an
invasion you've got
more battalion tactical groups actually
being brought closer uh to the border uh
with ukraine according to the
intelligence that we're seeing so
mixed signals i think at the moment and
all the more reason therefore for us to
remain very tough and and very united
and particularly
on the economic sanctions and and that
uh what we're doing as you know the uk
has been out in the in the lead for for
a while what we're doing is uh targeting
particular russian banks russian
companies and making sure that we
take steps or take even more steps to
unpeel the facade of uh russian property
holdings uh whether in this city or
elsewhere whether in london or elsewhere
unpeel the facade of
russian ownership of companies
and also take steps to stop russian
companies
from raising capital on london financial
markets now that is a very very tough uh
package of sanctions uh it's ready to go
if there is uh if russia is so uh so
rash so so reckless is to invade ukraine
i've got a question on that in a second
but first you mentioned intelligence
there are reports that the u.s
intelligence
believe that an invasion could happen at
1am does that fit with the uk's
understanding so
we think that
they have a huge preparation ready to go
at virtually any time um 130 000 troops
or more
a huge number of uh
more than 90 battalion tactical groups
and they are stationed around the the
ukrainian border everybody can see uh
what the potential routes in are uh down
uh to the south from from belarus uh
encircling the uh the ukrainian army in
the east around the uh the the area
there that uh the enclave in donbass or
even coming up from the south uh from
the sea uh taking uh odessa uh herzon uh
that's the kind of thing they can he
there are a lot of options that they
have
and therefore what does vladimir putin
need to do to reassure you
and other western leaders because you
don't sound reassured today i think what
everybody needs to see is a a program of
de-escalation
and you know we're here what does that
mean that means withdrawing the
battalion tactical groups away from a
potential theater of
conflict uh
not constructing uh field hospitals uh
on the border with uh with belarus and
between paris and and ukraine uh a sense
that things are being scaled back scaled
down uh that the
threat is is over and that a
conversation a negotiation is beginning
we think there is an avenue for uh
diplomacy we've seen some uh some
positive signs from conversations with
between uh mr ushkov and his american
counterpart between sergey lavrov
and others and you know if that's if
that's correct then let's build on that
some critics
argue that you and other westerners may
have been played by vladimir putin
because the fact that so many
politicians are traveling to russia the
fact that russian demands are now being
discussed by all of us some would argue
means that vladimir putin has already
succeeded whatever happens here what's
your response to that that's why it's so
important joe that we support
ukraine and that we show that we have a
package of tough very very tough uh
economic sanctions ready to go and that
we support ukraine military in the way
that we are the uk has been out in the
front in delivering uh
defensive but lethal military aid in the
form of the anti-tank weapons as well as
the as the training that we've done over
many many years the uk has been giving a
lot of support to ukraine final thing i
would mention this is a a very difficult
decision that we've just
taken and that is to
uh
to keep our embassy going in kiev and
to continue to ask melinda simmons our
fantastic ambassador to do uh what she's
doing now that's a balanced decision we
have to face the fact that uh there is a
risk and we'll keep it under constant
review but one of the things we want to
do is to show the uk's continued support
for ukraine for stability in ukraine and
i believe that keeping our embassy going
for as long as possible is is an
important symbol
finally you talk about sanctions on the
topic of money laundering some of your
conservative colleagues especially
senior figures on the back benches say
that this government hasn't done enough
to stop the flow of dirty money into
this country can you promise that the
economic crime bill will be in the next
queen speech so i i don't think that
it's it's it's fair to say the uk hasn't
done uh a huge amount on on dirty money
uh whether it's from russia or anywhere
else and we've actually been globally
we've been out in the lead in in
tackling uh global uh corruption in uh
in in tracing the the the sources of
ill-gotten gains and uh
we were one of the we have imposed some
very tough sanctions if you recall after
the uh the russian invasion of
uh or the russian annexation of of
crimea of sevastopol in 2014 those
sanctions remain in place we have
sanctions against everybody involved in
the poisoning of alexey navalny uh for
instance
but what we want to do is strengthen now
uh the package that we have uh
strengthen the measures we have against
uh you know potential ill-gotten uh
russian money whether here or anywhere
in the uh anywhere
for which we have responsibility with uh
new measures that will hit the companies
and concerns that i've i've talked about
but also uh open up the the the
matryoshka doll if you like you know
what i'm talking about so that we see uh
which uh who really owns uh the
companies that we're talking about who
really owns the properties that we're
talking about and those measures uh yes
we will be bringing forward from the
economic crime bill
yes
thank you